[Musique]
partout les hommes peinent mtv il est
présent né dans les salons il a envoûté
et conquis la rue le piano du pauvre
piano à bretelles qui n'en finit pas
d'inspirer des souvenirs de grandes
fêtes et grandes luttes populaires
compagnon d amende et laisser des marins
à l'ats me grise l'accordéon devient le
porte voix des cinéastes populiste et
des années 30 et surtout des poètes
qu'il aime d'amour comme souvenirs de
jeunesse
[Musique]
les souvenirs que j'ai moi de la rue de
lattre vis divise en deux il ya des
souvenirs de la journée l'arrêt de l'avs
est à fréquenter habitée par des gens
qui travaillent et qui rentrait le soir
leur travail il y avait ceux qui
travaillaient dans la rue de lappe même
qui avait des magasins de machines de
salaison nous verne et je crois que le
soir à partir de 9h du soir et les
danseurs
descendez d'ailleurs je crois qu'il
descendait de la zone et se laver le
costume traditionnel des apaches la
casquette octogonale bien placé de
travers sur la chevelure bien gominés
adhérents flattait bien et fils et qu'il
descendait qui descendait jusqu'où des
ça vous l'avez vraiment un message les
vues je vais peut-être vous êtes que je
l'embellie avec mon souvenir d'enfance
car je me souviens également des muses
des gigolettes coiffée à la garçonne
avec le petit foulard de côté la petite
jupe plissée et les talons les souliers
aux talons arrêt de l'appareil de la
route dans joyeux
où les frappes de rouler propre étaient
chez eux par lui de l'art de rue de là
peu en ce temps-là à petits pas ont
danser la java ee
je le portais les casquettes sur le
voilà je suis né ici il y avait donc un
pâle bruit et aux fondus palin qui l'est
ce qui fait qu'elle ait jamais vécue
soleil dans cette chambre
alors c'est peut-être pour ça que mes
parents ont décidé mais ça je ne sais
pas en quelle année de déménager et ils
sont plus de pièces sur la rue au
deuxième étage
puisqu'il y avait deux maîtres venus
aussi c'est qu'on l'avait des spectacles
extraordinaires parce qu il y avait
énormément de bal musette
on l'attendait l'anosy moi j'ai été
bercé véritablement à l'accordéon juste
jusqu'à la déclaration d'hier
je m'endormais au son de l'accordéon y
avait un bal qui était pas loin qui
s'appelle bal du club et j'avais les
échos de l'accordéon qui monte jusque
dans la chambre et dans mon lit moi je
m'endormais des recettes en la
considérant qu'elle avait qu'avec
l'accord des eaux
il a calé et les gros mots vous avec les
gonzesses
il y avait trois quatre et le tambour le
new par le clairon et ses trois cafés
avaient chacun un petit orchestre hills
qui jouaient de la musique
il y avait les consommateurs à six aux
terrasses
et puis les badauds qui n'avaient pas de
sous donc j'étais debout de 9h à minuit
à écouter ce petit orchestre qui jouait
de 9h à minuit des sélections de carmen
la traviata des valses musettes des
déserts beaucoup plus populaires
[Musique]
les rues dans la nuit se ressent d'un
brunet le ciel aussi qu'il soit gris
nous sert un jour de la vie sont
bienvenus oui mais toi tu me ressembles
à personne
si tu crois que ça
il me fait me voir au dos
autrement dit n'est d'amphi si j'ai tort
générerait volant car pour
la personne
sais tu que le genre et bonheur
cependant comme ça
comme mon cas une femme ici ou
si des fois ça me suffit à voir et si
toute ma vie je n'ai qu'une seule envie
de voir comme ça l'était mais pour ça
car vois-tu qu'une ressemble à personne
les swaps et recoins voir dans l'amour
comme ça aucun autre
il semble
tu me demande pourquoi je vais me temps
tu dis qu'il y en a de plus joli que toi
c'est peut-être mais crois moi je sais
il ne garde qu'un tout seul
bonheur pour moi
c'est
à
ce que je voulais vous demander si c'est
tout
cette fois on est tellement longtemps un
passage ici c'était massage
oui c'est une grande voûte
il y avait un marchand de compas
moniteurs qui s'appelait l'oublier
toujours s'agit d'enfants à séguéla mais
je veux dire que c'est très jeune moi je
crois que mon conservatoire de musique
puisque j'ai pas fait le conservatoire
ça a été la rue de l'abbé ses accordéons
et c'est orchestre musette et
quelquefois des orchestres comme vous
dites un peu plus élaboré quoi qu'il
comprenait trois ou quatre musiciens pas
plus il y avait un accordéoniste a weak
la connerie ce qui m'avait stupéfié et
je me déplaçais jusqu'à la république
pour aller l'entendre il jouait au
balthazar
c'était deux princes
deprince il jouer les deux mains sur son
accordéon normalement et puis quand il
jouait présente la traviata ou guillaume
tell
il passait sa main droite sur son
clavier de basse et il faisait souffler
son accordéon qui jouait sur les deux
mains sur ses bases ça ça
m'impressionnait terriblement si tu ne
jouais de teutons quand même pas
monsieur francisque là on s'en fout
m
[Musique]
à
et si tu nous jouait le dénicheur tu
l'as eu tellement joué dans ta vie
non
m
[Musique]
ouais
ça doit difficile de retrouver les
chansons aussi ancien nom oui nous
retrouver la musique je veux dire oui
oui mais pourquoi faites vous ce travail
cette recherche pour mon plaisir parce
que j'aime bien me rappeler les airs
anciens que je voulais tant que c'est
tout ça me rappelle ma jeunesse on
rappelle un tas de souvenirs elle ça
vous êtes du nord monsieur le prince
doit être vous regroupez vous avez
commencé à jouer de l'accordéon très
jeune oui dans quelles circonstances
d'un parce que mon père jouait de
l'accordéon
oui alors c'est ce que c'est un gosse un
de bien faire compléter son père alors
il me payer un petit quoi
puis j'ai commencé à jouer vous avez
joué dans son café il tenait un café
oui oui oui racontez nous un peu ça
faisait plaisir aux gens parce que on
voyait pas souvent des gosses jouer de
la musique comme ça que c'est vrai
maintenant on en voit plus quel âge
aviez-vous bon bah je le 6 7 ans 8 ans
qu'est ce que représente l accordéon
pour les gens à l'époque j'étais un peu
pas tellement bien
bien regroupés dans la société
peu snob on n'aimait pas ça pourquoi ne
sais pas c'est pas c'était vraiment lui
l'instrument d'ouvriers comprenait la
l'ouvrier mais savait mais si on allait
vers les gens un peu enfin ça plaisait
pas non et par la suite alors on a fait
des progrès d'ailleurs il faut dire que
au début un accordéon était mal conçu
avec s'était dit à tony qu'on ne pouvait
pas jouer en chose c'était les teaser
des petites chansons et puis alors après
il ya quand même eu l'accordéon qui
s'est transformée on accorde un
chromatique
c'est à dire le diatonique c'est cet
instant pour tirer à 100 pouces et alors
que le chromatique ces poussées tiens
c'est la même note
vous avez connu la transformation ah oui
ah oui on a une photo de vous avec votre
premier accordéon d'ailleurs on va la
voir tout de suite oui oui on dansait
dans ses pas en écouter ça pourquoi
est-ce qu'on dansait part c'était les
fonctionnaires perdront mentionnons les
cafés annoncé se faisait pas même pas un
petit tour de valse non non non il y
avait des bals mais non mais vous étiez
environné par l'accordéon c'est ça c'est
ça et même les gens chanter avec pierre
fin à tout ça c'était sympathique scène
oui il y avait toujours quelqu'un qui
chantait alors on accompagne et c'était
ça vous voyez le jouer un air que vous
jouiez quand vous étiez enfant
oui peut-être bien
on va le faire
[Musique]
huawei
et
ensuite vous êtes allé à calais oui oui
alors c'est une ville particulière
qu'elle est oui ben il y avait beaucoup
de navigateurs vous savez travailler
beaucoup d'anglais à des anglais des
norvégiens suédois je parle de toi peut
tout et toutes les nations quoi alors il
fallait joue un peu le répertoire
international ciel est alors en plus y
avait sur les sur les tables y avait une
espèce de petit dit almanach avec tout
le répertoire de répertoire on avait
tous répertoires numérotées alors les
clients demandés soit par exemple une
petite chanson zéro franc 10 bons
amorçant un peu plus sérieux je reprends
vain une ouverture 0.50 enfin et alors
ces deux garçons qui nous apportait la
pièce qui mettait ça dans le temps et
qui nous disait denis leroy jouer alors
je veux comme ça vous étiez payé à la
pièce
non non tu payes et par l'établissement
mais seulement ça c'était un supplément
l'instant là je suis arrivé à paris
c'est l entre-deux-guerres là oui
j'étais mauvais cette terre attendaient
1,31
qu'est ce qui a changé dans le
répertoire de l'accordéon depuis vos
débuts jusqu'aux années d'avant-guerre
dix ans le style il ya eu pendant une
bonne période
c'était vraiment le musée qui compte et
vous savez
[Musique]
m
tout de suite après être entré de
prisonniers j'ai donc travaillé dans les
cafés c'est à dire la renaissance les
uns balthazar tout ça et puis j'ai fait
les boîtes de nuit oui oui oui ça
travailler oui oui oui oui je peux vous
raconter une chose qui m'est arrivé
c'est que il y avait un monsieur qui
venait monsieur bien tous les soirs dans
la boîte où je travaillais et nous avons
pu dire le nom de cet endroit oui
c'était au doj derrière l'opéra alors il
nous avait demandé si on voulait bien
joué ça sent si bon la france alors on
du jeu ça qui nous donne cinq mille
francs de l'époque ce qui représentait
beaucoup d'argent gentil le lendemain il
revient on voit arriver une nous ne nous
a pas demandé si glee on doit jouer tout
de suite on encore ils s'amuseront mais
il ne s'est pas moins quatre cinq fois
par semaine à chaque fois en année alors
que t on le soignait le garçon parce que
les balles ça a commencé à la libération
alors là les gens avaient soir des
danses et la france on veut qu on ne
connaissait bien oui c'est oui parce que
je faisais des radios défaut nous tous
un peu j'avais quand même un an déjà
dans le métier
c'était comment les bars à ce moment là
les gens étaient gays ah oui tout à fait
et ça se passait toujours très bien vous
aviez un orchestre
ah oui mais on était sept musiciens et
ça tournait bien tout de suite après la
guerre il ya eu un engouement ou savage
les les gens voulaient danser vous
laissera en somme se rattraper cette
église écrit qu'il était vraiment gay
est rayé qu'est ce qui a changé
aujourd'hui dans l'utilisation de
l'accordéon
à votre avis maintenant c'est devenu un
instrument complet on arrive à jouer des
choses maintenant vous savez formidable
d'ailleurs il ya quelques petits gars à
l'heure actuelle qui sont terribles et
qui jouent vraiment des choses qu'on
arrive même à jouer difficilement au
piège
[Musique]